this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with breast cancer this
video will help you understand how to
manage it
breast cancer is a type of cancer that
begins in the cells of the breast
for many women treatments for breast
cancer may remove or destroy the cancer
afterward you should receive a follow-up
care plan from your health care team
this includes going to follow-up
appointments
your doctor will want to make sure the
cancer has not returned and check for
health problems resulting from treatment
it's also important to get regular
mammograms to check for breast cancer as
recommended by your doctor
if you are on any medications continue
to take them as prescribed by your
doctor
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if you had breast surgery or other
treatments follow any instructions you
were given
you may also need to make some of the
following healthy lifestyle changes
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables beans and whole grains a
healthy diet may reduce your risk of
cancer or the chance of it coming back
it's also important for you to stay
physically active
moderate activities like walking riding
a bicycle or swimming can help you feel
better and less tired
ask your doctor to recommend a physical
therapist or exercise specialist that
can help you design the right exercise
plan for you and a nutritionist to help
you design the right diet or food plan
for you
quitting smoking and limiting alcohol
intake
can help reduce your risk of cancer
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming
you may have worries about things like
your condition and how it affects your
family
treatments and hospital stays
medical bills
and your job
fortunately there are ways to cope with
this
remember that your doctor and health
care team are there to answer any
questions you have
some of the following sources of support
can help you cope with your concerns
social workers
church leaders
counselors
and support groups
talk to your doctor if you have any
questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage breast cancer